terrorisme délinquance éducation des
sujets qui sont familiers à jean
frédéric poisson
ces trois thématiques seront notamment
abordés lors du second débat de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
ce jeudi 3 novembre sur terrorisme je
suis certainement une ce qui est le plus
haut fait de
du terrorisme et en particulier du
fonctionnement de dèche
je suis un universitaire donc je connais
bien les thématiques éducative
je travaille les questions
internationales des questions
européennes
j'ai passé douze ans de ma vie dans les
banlieues sensibles du nord de paris
donc je suis intarissable sur les
questions de sécurité
entre deux signatures pour la communauté
d'agglomération rambouillet territoire
jean frédéric poisson pense à la manière
d'aborder ce second débat je prépare de
la même manière que le premier ce qui a
fait la réussite de ce premier débat
c'est que je ne crois pas encore une
fois qu'il faille profusion de chiffres
le problème n'est pas de faire des
effets d'annoncé
j'ai une voix qui dénote par rapport à
la dominante idéologique on peut dire ça
comme ça des représentants de la droite
et du centre en tout cas tels qu'ils
sont engagés dans la primaire
et surtout j'ai voulu essayer de
manifester que les français ont besoin
qu'on leur parle de politique et pas
simplement de gestion son directeur de
campagne charles-henri jamin coordonne
l'équipe chargée de travailler sur les
thématiques et confirme la sensation
créée par son candidat lors de la
première confrontation pas si clair il a
gagné 30 points de 30 points de
notoriété en une soirée ce qui
globalement se faire en 12 15 ou 20 ans
les objectifs du deuxième débat c'est de
confirmer jean falala poisson comme
étant la personne et comme je viens de
vous le dire qui porte un vrai projet
une vraie vision qui correspondent aux
attentes des français
le premier tour de la primaire de la
droite et du centre se déroulera le 21
novembre